vous avez peut-être d'y passer la
nouvelle des étudiants ont fait une
grève de la faim pour forcer
l'université mémorial a abandonné tous
ses placements relié aux énergies
fossiles
un manifestant a été hospitalisé mais
surtout ils ont fait plus l'université
l'urgence est là il faut maintenant agir
aujourd'hui pour la suite de notre série
sur les finances on vous parlait de
désinvestissements
[Musique]
à l'échelle de la planète 85 % de
l'énergie provient des combustibles
fossiles québec fait pas exception même
si on à l'hydroélectricité on va quand
même apporté 150 millions dollar et
pétrole par année il vise 10 milliards
de mètres cube de gaz naturel ça ça fait
beaucoup de gaz à effet de serre et
beaucoup d'argent
[Musique]
concrètement d investir ça veut dire
quoi on pose la question à une sommité
du secteur de l'énergie
l'économiste jean thomas bernard quand
on parle de désinvestissement c'est
qu'elle renonce où l'on retire ces fonds
où on relance investir dans certains
secteurs s'inscrivent damas dans la
volonté d'appuyer la transition vers des
formes d'énergies renouvelables donc
diminuer les fonds accessibles aux
entreprises qui opèrent
le mouvement du désinvestissement est
apparue une dizaine d'années à la suite
de pressions ou encore par conviction
des fonds d'investissement choisi de se
retirer de certains secteurs polluants
comme le pétrole le charbon et le gaz
on peut penser notamment à la caisse de
dépôt et placement du québec qui a
promis de liquider ses actifs pétroliers
d'ici la fin de 2020 10 pour le bien de
l'économie c'est pour le bien de la
société dans son ensemble à l'échelle
mondiale des données cumulées par des
groupes écologistes estiment que près de
1500 gestionnaire de fonds aurait vendu
40 mille milliards de dollars
inaccessible à l'industrie des
combustibles fossiles
on sera pas cacher il ya plusieurs
banques qui n'ont pas encore reçu le
message depuis la signature de l'accord
de paris les banques canadiennes
investie pas loin de 700 milliards de
dollars dans l'industrie pétrolière et
gazière c'est à peu près le contraire du
désinvestissement
jean philippe renault fait ce qu'on
appelle de l'engagement actionnarial son
travail c'est de représenter des gros
investisseurs auprès d'entreprises
publiques
selon lui la clé n'est pas seulement de
désinvestir le changement climatique est
un jeu excessivement complexe fait des
gros acteurs qui sont très amis présents
dans l'industrie et on peut pas
simplement les ignorer faire semblant
qu'il n'existe pas dire moi j'suis pas
investi là dessus je ne vois pas chante
en poche je veux rien savoir lorsqu'on
retire ses billes d'une entreprise on
n'a plus le droit de parole on voit très
aux assemblées générales on peut pas
proposer un nouvel administrateur on
peut pas demander une meilleure
reddition de comptes on n'a pas droit de
parole donc qu en tant qu on vote aux
entreprises d'antan qu'on détient leur
dette ou leur leur action ont une
certaine influence avec son entreprise
sans aucun doute
parce que nous on sort n'obéit que ces
entreprises ne cessent d'exister encore
moins que ces actifs le stress d'exister
donc une mine de sables bitumineux va
rester en opération pour des dizaines
d'années les bassins de rétention des
sables bitumineux vont continuer à
exister les rapports difficiles avec les
premières nations les huit cent mille
travailleurs qui sont dans cette
industrie là et qui vont devoir se
reformer transitionner vers d'autres
industries eux ils continuent être donc
on doit travailler avec ces entreprises
là pour améliorer tous ces enjeux
[Musique]
ces gros émetteurs reste sur le terrain
mais leurs propriétaires à eux ont
commencé à sortir donc on ne les voit
plus sont plus dans les grandes caisses
de retraite canadiennes
ils sont plus dans les grandes familles
canadiennes difficile à comprendre qu'
eu comment par qui ces détenus le petit
moment donc moi c'est ma grande crainte
quand on veut sortir n'obéissant
vraiment penser aux conséquences
au canada et aux états unis le pétrole
est produit par des entreprises cotées
en bourse
ce sont sur ces compagnies que le
désinvestissement souhaite agir mais il
y a aussi le pétrole des pays membres de
l'opep plus du pétrole nationaliser sur
lequel le désinvestissement n'aurait pas
beaucoup d'emprise
[Musique]
55 % du pétrole présent provient de ses
piles dans ces pays là le pétrole est
produit par des sociétés d'état pour à
l'arabie saoudite ces rames cohérent ne
reliera qyrool donc et c'est le
gouvernement qui décide donc leur site
ne sont pas allés jusqu'à la bouche la
partie marché somme toute elle n'est pas
si important que ça en réduisant la
production des entreprises qui comme ici
au canada opèrent dans des conditions de
marché mais on va favoriser la
transition vers des entreprises
houle le pétrole et ce contrôle
gouvernemental
des investissements c'est pas un outil
qui est très efficace pour
l'objectif qui est qui est recherché le
problème de base
évidemment la production mais y'a
production parce que la demande pour ses
services
la baisse de prix de ses actions ne
s'est pas matérialisée par ce qu un
mouvement d investissement elles ont été
investies ailleurs dans certains cas
certains actifs là des mines des
raffineries ont été vendus à l'étranger
vendu à des fonds privés des fonds
souverains mais les cent plus gros
pollueurs au canada reste les cent plus
gros pollueurs au canada
le mouvement du désinvestissement ne pas
couper les vivres à l'industrie des
combustibles fossiles mais il a atteint
un autre objectif envoyer un message
clair qu'une autre finances est possible
une vie dense plus sobre en carbone
chose certaine rendre accessible
quarante mille milliards de dollars à
des secteurs qui appuient la transition
ça aura certainement aidé à développer
de nouvelles formes d'énergie qui
remplaceront un jour le pétrole
pour notre dernier reportage sur les
finances marianne vos creuse une
question importante le capitalisme est
ce que c'est compatible avec la santé
notre planète est ce qu'on devrait
changer de modèle économique
[Rires]
oui
on n'aura pas et la croissance et
finalement la stabilisation à
l'amélioration discrétion sur le père de
me fallait choisir un des outils
puissants changement danos assez peu
animées à ckac tahrir
[Musique]